what will be the biggest stories of the
year ahead in 2019 the driverless
revolution finally hits the road so this
is science fiction that's going to
become science fact new tech pays
tribute to the old masters you'll have
an explosion of Leonardo mania in 2019
flights will be cheaper than ever and
fifty years after the riots that
kick-started the modern gay rights
movement the fight goes global
[Music]
[Applause]
in 2019 power dressing will take on a
whole new meaning when this
strange-looking clothing hits the market
not so much high fashion as high tech
it's a suit with built-in power that
will literally get people moving the
suit that we're introducing in 2019 is
actually an assist suit so you have to
be moving think of it kind of like an
electric bicycle you're pedaling and
getting extra power part of the wearable
robotics revolution the suit is made up
of battery-powered muscle packs which
contract just like a human muscle to
boost the wearer's strength those
robotic muscles that we're providing
actually turn on and provide strength to
the body in a coordinated way when you
need it while you're moving with the
global population of over 60s expected
to more than double by 2050 and
retirement age increasing there's no
shortage of potential markets in Japan
the average age of a construction
workers 48 so there's lots of demand for
the labor workforce them but don't
expect the suits to ease the burden on
aching limbs and overstretched health
services anytime soon as these suits
don't come cheap
according to the manufacturer they'll
retail for around the cost of a bespoke
tailored suit the challenge globally is
how do we get such technologies to
everybody it doesn't happen in the way
that say for example Formula One
technology eventually trickles down into
the average car
you
20:19 will be the year low-cost
long-haul travel takes off you'll be
able to buy a ten thousand mile flight
from London to Sydney for around three
hundred and fifty dollars and this is
why the world will boast two new
state-of-the-art mega harp airports and
competition between them will drive down
the cost of flying doxing Airport
outside Beijing is due to open in 2019
and will feed growing demand for air
travel in China over the next 20 years
the number of Chinese air passengers is
set to triple Beijing already has one of
the world's biggest airports and for
China this new mega hub will send an
important message to the world the
opening of taxing airport is a symbol
that the center of the world's economy
has shifted East China rivaling taxing
as a national symbol of global prestige
will be a new mega hub airport in
Istanbul opened in 2018 it covers a
staggering 26 square miles an area
larger than the island of Manhattan and
in 2019 consumers will again be the
beneficiaries of a state sponsored
economic push the Turkish government has
actually been giving fuel subsidies to
its Airlines to try and help bring the
tourism industry back but the low fares
offered by competition between these
hubs could be short-lived in a few years
many airlines will begin offsetting
their carbon with the costs potentially
passed down to passengers it could
describe 2019 perhaps as being the year
to fly because who knows what's going to
happen to air fares when the airlines
actually have to start paying to offset
their emissions
we discovered that Americans consider
homosexuality more harmful to society
than adultery abortion or prostitution
in 2019 LGBT communities will mark the
anniversary of a seminal event it will
be 50 years since patrons at New York
gay bar the Stonewall Inn resisted
police attempts to arrest them the
resulting Stonewall riots kick-started
the modern gay rights movement
I think anniversaries like the Stonewall
Riots are important because they remind
us just how far we've come but also how
much change is still needed because
those sorts of repressions and violence
is still happening in much of the world
in many regions the laws that continue
to allow intolerance and inequality have
their roots in religion the these laws
originate from two main sources Sharia
law and the British colonial exportation
of Christian principles but one former
British colony has given hope to the
global movement for change in 2018 India
decriminalized homosexuality and gay
rights campaigners hope 2019 will be the
year other former British colonies
follow suit
in February Kenya's High Court will rule
on whether to decriminalize same-sex
intimacy which is currently punishable
with up to 14 years in prison
decriminalization would mean for the
first time LGBT Kenyans
would start to participate within the
Kenyan democracy as equals
we're going to be just a step closer to
figuring out how can equal Kenya looks
like
campaign is home but decriminalization
could start a domino effect across
Africa I think it will be a tipping
point for Africa it will be the
beginning of the unraveling of these
laws the Stonewall rises fought for the
right to be free and fundamental human
rights will remain at the top of the
agenda for sexual and gender freedom in
2019
[Music]
in 2019 people are actually going to be
paying to take Robo taxis in some cities
in America at least so this is sort of
science fiction that's going to become
science fact with GM launching its
driverless taxi service and way mo
expanding its Robo taxis to new cities
2019
will be the year the driverless car
revolution hits the road so 2019 is a
race to the starting line I think what
gets interesting is when this technology
starts to scale-up reach more cities and
ultimately more people have access to
this really great technology Nightrider
it was hit 1980s TV show Knight Rider
that popularized self-driving cars
controlled by artificial intelligence
since then billions of dollars of
investment have fueled the drive to turn
the idea into reality Dubai has
committed to a quarter of all trips
being driverless by 2030 and the
driverless car industry will be worth a
predicted five hundred and fifty billion
dollars by 2026 we're talking very very
large numbers and that number reflects
the optimism that this is going to be a
very significant technology in the
future
[Music]
but the advance of driverless cars could
be held up by a red flag as in March of
2018 the first person was killed by a
self-driving car at the moment about
40,000 people are killed on the roads in
America alone each year
so if imagine if you improve safety by
99 percent so you you then are talking
about 400 road deaths a year I think
that would still be quite a hard sell
that's somebody being killed by a Robo
taxi every day but manufacturers are
confident that the inevitable progress
of technology will win over the skeptics
there is no cap on what a computer could
do in terms of safety they'll just get
better and better every year I think you
could pretty quickly see a flip from I
don't want to share the road with these
killer machines too I don't want to
share the road with these killer humans
anymore
may 20 19 will mark 500 years since the
death of the greatest polymath in global
history Leonardo da Vinci I think you'll
have an explosion of Leonardo mania in
2019 Leonardo painted the world's most
expensive picture the Salvator Mundi
which was auctioned for 450 million
dollars but he was also have brilliant
scientists an engineer in 2019 his art
and notebooks will be taking center
stage at blockbuster exhibitions if I
could have an afternoon with Leonardo da
Vinci I'd show him the Internet because
he would be so thrilled at the way we
can now have ways to be curious about
anything we want to know Leonardo
sketched out designs for inventions that
followed centuries later such as scuba
equipment
and the tank and in 2019 another of his
designs will be getting a new lease of
life as a flying car becomes
commercially available the car flies
thanks to folding helicopter blades
which had derived from Leonardo's
invention the aerial screw leonardo
would have loved the concept of a flying
car look at that aerial screw that was
designed as a prop for a play to bring
angels down from the rafters but then
Leonardo blurs the fantasy into reality
as since the rest of his life trying to
build a real flying machine
leonardo was the original outsider he's
illegitimate he's left-handed he's a
vegetarian he's gay he wears short
purple tunics but they love him in
Florence they embrace him and that's the
cool thing about the Renaissance was
that embrace people who were sometimes
naturally weird five centuries after his
death there are still simple lessons he
can teach today's divided world Leonardo
was very tolerant he realized that we
should bring people together not
separate into tribe these are the type
of things that were still trying to
learn in 2019 500 years after he died
[Music]
you